[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 as always my name is Caleb Ben B
and I'll be your driver on this journey
today I wanted to take a look at a few
games that I actually just played over
last weekend at the US Amateur Team East
also known as the world amateur team
tournament way over in Parsippany New
Jersey it was a it was a fun event it's
always a very well-organized event it's
one of the the biggest events actually
in the country for chess with just under
I think 1500 players this year I think
they were right around the 1400 markets
it's pretty crazy how many players
actually come out for this thing I
played some good games and I played some
bad games but I think most of them were
pretty instructive so today I wanted to
go over a win a draw and a loss from my
tournament here so I'll let you guys
pick the order the win the draw or the
loss what do you want to see what do you
want to see hands up for win
nobody wants to see the win hands up for
draw and okay let's start with the loss
everybody all right here we go
so this is a game played between
actually let me just type in his name
here our salon og EV now who knows our
salon og EV nobody
I barely know who our salon og Eva's he
is a I think professional UFC fighter
so that was pretty interesting you can
look him up I think he's got a fight
available on YouTube I watched it prior
to prior to the round to see what I was
up against in debts it's pretty
terrifying stuff but in chess he is a
feat a master around the 2400 USCF mark
and he played one efore against me I
responded with c6 the caro-kann d4 d5
92 so this 92 Don is as much the same as
the Knight c3 line for me you take on e4
in the knight recaptures bishop comes
out to f5 and i comes back to beat
back to g3 bishop g6 h4 for those
familiar with the CARICOM this is one of
the main main lines of the classical
Carrick on h4 of course is actually
threatening to trap blacks Bishop so
black responds with h6 creating a little
hidey hole for it and then the mainline
continues with Knight f3 + h5 but my
opponent played c3 which is a move that
I had not seen before that the database
have not seen before but can't really be
too too wrong right it's it's fine he
strengthens the center so what do you do
when your opponent plays a move you're
not familiar with in the opening but
looks pretty non-threatening what should
you do just in general
yeah Jim stick to the basics so what are
the basics here you want to get your
pieces developed so what moves do you
think blacks should play
knights and bishops right so you want to
get these pieces out specifically in the
caro-kann it's a good idea to play e6
pretty much as as quickly as possible
because it's nice to have the
opportunity to get this Bishop out to
this very important diagonal here so I
responded with with a six-night f6 also
would have been a fine move 97 would
have been a little bit more offbeat
because it's good to get your Kings side
developed so you can get this King
castled if you really need to does this
matter to you Ben oh yeah well it's gone
yeah right no no maintenance so II 6
getting ready to develop the pieces
white plays Knight e 2 in this move
actually is a little bit dangerous for
black here to be a bit careful here so
what are the most natural moves for
black to get developed here most natural
what do you think
we hear a big truck going by Bishop e7
so actually that one wouldn't actually
make my list but yes developing this
Bishop is one of the most natural things
to do here in this case though the d6
square is actually better for this for
this Bishop normally in the Cairo it
does come to e7 but here because white
isn't really playing for the g4 g5 plan
d6 is is a slightly better square you
want to take this diagonal away from
from White's bishop
so Bishop d6 or Bishop e7 it's not a bad
move normally these are some of the most
natural ways to get developed also
Knight f6 is very natural right there's
actually a pretty significant problem
though with one of these ways of playing
either Knight f6 or developing this
Bishop one of those two has a pretty
major problem and I'll ask you to try
and find why one of these is wrong and
which one it is someone in YouTube wants
to play c5 but I would advise you to
first develop your pieces before
planning for for this pawn break it's
very important to get developed
especially in an opening like the Cairo
where you're kind of playing with less
space
so this is a pretty difficult question
if you're not familiar with what the
karo but it has to do with whites last
move Knight eetu rather than Knight f3
hey Tristan welcome
so what square is is y tying up with 92
yeah F 4 right and then that actually
makes a pretty significant threat to our
Bishop so we'll have to move the bishop
and then from there White's next move
might might cause some problems
I'll get rid of some arrows for you so
blacks most natural developing moose I'm
saying or Knight f6 or Bishop d6 but one
of these two moves is actually pretty
bad for black one of these two moves
comes with the problem yeah breath yes
that's exactly right
so Bishop d6 or Bishop e7 are both
actually pretty big mistakes here this
afternoon I have for this Bishop has to
move and the knight h5 and there's no
real comfortable way for black to solve
this problem you definitely don't want
to play move like Bishop f6 and allow
this trade the dark squared bishop is
pretty important here for for black and
so white would have a pretty nice edge
so for that reason also Bishop d6 I want
to mention you definitely don't want to
be taking this Knight because you're
allowing white to get developed with
tempo and once again the dark squared
Bishop is a little bit too important for
black so it's much better to keep this
Bishop on f8 and just develop this
Knight
so always be on the lookout even early
on for these types of threats
fortunately for me I was kind of
familiar with this idea by white so I
kind of saw this coming a bit and knew
to develop the knight this night comes
out to f4 anyways Bishop h7 and Knight
f2 to age 5 and so now at this point I
was I was kind of totally off-book I
thought I had made this move not so good
but by keeping my bishop on f8 so I
didn't panic I knew I hadn't done
anything wrong simply developed my other
pieces white also develops with Bishop
c4 and now I still have this problem
where I can't really develop this Bishop
so how do you solve it as black hair how
do you solve your problems
oh hello Eric that might be actually
judging by the spelling of Eric and the
YouTube chat might be one of my later
opponents yeah that's a good point
if you take the night white word
recapture and you've still got the same
problem with with g7 yeah but then you
could bring this other knight to f6
right so that's one way to solve it and
actually in the game I couldn't find any
other way to reasonably solve the
problems so I did what I saw I actually
captured and played the southern Knight
to f6 and it turns out this is fine for
black this is this is actually the way
you should be playing so even though it
does seem as though it's it's wasting a
bit of time for black the important
thing is this is actually the fastest
way to get developed if you're black
here there's there's no faster way to do
it and white has also wasted some time
by bringing these pieces out quite so
far so black is doing fine here white
actually castles King side I captured
this this other night on h5 as I
intended to to get this Bishop develops
and after Queen takes h5 White has
actually presented me with a new problem
what threat has has white actually made
here yeah of course it's it's Bishop e6
and this pin is is slightly awkward
it's very notable that's say I just
developed this is the move I want to
play if Bishop takes Bishop g6 actually
doesn't really help my cause white will
simply play either queen g4 or Queen e2
and now if I take well for one this is
hanging and for two I can actually take
here and then take here so Bishop d6 is
a valid threat so I have to do something
about it I had a couple options here
you could play Bishop g6 or you could
maybe just defend this pawn somehow
Queen d7 Queen f6
so the threat to the Queen makes sure
that that white does in fact have to
move this point first but after Queen G
for this threat would be renewed which I
guess is worth saying but then maybe I
was thinking simply Bishop f5 here would
be a good way to to keep everything
totally defended for the moment and it
turns out mr. g6 with this position that
has actually been reached I think once
or twice before and Bishop g6 was played
in both of those games I went for a
little bit of a different plan with
Queen f6 which is also fine for black
white responds with rook e1 which of
course actually renews the threat and
then my plan in the game is what I
followed through on and it was to Castle
queenside so this is looking a little
bit dangerous now right the game is not
not quite so simple anymore notably the
other games I think if we we follow them
a bit with mission g6 queen g4 Queen f6
h h5 Bishop f5 22:3 black also cast as
Queen side in these games I just did
everything in a little bit of a
different order so still following kind
of the the beaten path here castles and
now Queen a5 so quit I 5 makes a threat
how should you respond to this threat
you have kind of two options you can
defend the pawn with King b8 or you
could go a little bit a little bit
crazier so what's the other option
besides King b8 let's see if you guys
can figure it out a six definitely don't
want to play a six a six you're asking
you're asking to get demolished here
don't want to play like this don't want
to play like this yeah this is how your
opponent wins brilliant surprises you
hate those no brilliancy prizes for your
opponents
yep
yes the coin h4 is is a pretty valid
idea here I don't know if this is the
exact order you actually want to do it
in because now white might gain this
tempo back with g3 and you'll have to
retreat your queen and then after you
take sunday 7 it turns out the a7 pond
might have been a little bit more
important than than the h4 pond here but
you can actually do things in a slightly
different order where if you start with
Bishop d6 now after Queen I 7 Queen
takes h4 you're actually making a pretty
significant threat here and what would
black play in response to g3 in this
case just shout it out yeah of course
you just take this pawn off the board
similar to what white would do after a 6
so the Bishop d6 is actually the best
move here
I played King b8 in the game which is
bad only to the move Bishop f4 which is
a very nice idea by white of course this
bishops untouchable due to this rook and
after Bishop d6 this is still ok for
black but white white does have some
pull here actually figure out what the
best response is for white so yessum
simply takes and then h5 and once again
the dark screw bishop was was kind of
important for black and and now it is
dead and gone so that's why Bishop d6
first was a bit better it prevents this
Bishop f4 option for white instead
though my opponent played Bishop e3 so
who sees the idea behind Bishop e3 what
nasty intentions does white have here
some very nasty intentions yeah yes d5
is is White's idea and he wants to kill
you and so I didn't want to get killed
but at the same time I calculated a bit
and if I learned one lesson from this
tournament it's that I'm not very good
at calculating so know what I have to
work on but I decided that the d5 black
should actually be doing okay as long as
I have some defense along this diagonal
so I continued with this move Bishop d6
anyways noting that after d5 which was
played pawn takes for one I have a
pretty significant threat to this Bishop
and for to this bishop along this
diagonal is always going to be able to
help defend a little bit it's going to
guard some of these squares and so for
that reason I did take on my opponent
still did play d5 because he's kind of
committed to this idea at this point if
you play something like g3 it's it's all
just a bit a bit unimpressive
I can play move like Bishop c7 start
kicking your queen around I can get my
other rooks into the game I can play
moves like g5 to trip open the Kings
side further you don't want to give
black too much time here so my opponent
played ambitiously with d5 and after tix
he does take on a 7 and after queening
it actually in this case rather than
play Bishop b8 I simply play King c7 now
my opponent played Queen i5 and I played
King c8 hoping he would repeat because
big scary UFC fighter FM I'm okay with a
draw for the team and unfortunately for
me he chose to play the move
b4 here b4 which is pretty terrifying
actually pretty terrifying so let's say
I pass and we do the same thing as last
time he plays Queen e8 and I play King
c7 who spots the difference that b4
makes here what extra choice does does
white have
uh yeah well let's let's let's I just
want to see what White's threat is why
did white play b4 because white did make
it threat and it's kind of a nasty one
kind of a nasty one doesn't feel good
when you see it sure yeah not Bishop c5
not Bishop c6 Bishop b6 we've got a
winner there should be six and what's
the idea if you take it
Queen I five mate right of course the
pawn provides the support for the Queen
and if the King steps to the side we are
not taking this rook we're instead
playing queen b7 with a nice checkmate
to the king
so notably White has made a threat with
b4 but question is can you willfully
ignore it and take this bishop and now
this is a very very difficult question I
thought for some time in the game and
decided I should take the bishop it
turns out that white has enough for a
draw after after pawn takes Bishop but
there is actually a move here that's
simply winning for the black player
there's a move here that wins the game
and I've already given you a large hint
it's not pawn takes Bishop White has
enough for a draw after pawn takes
Bishop but I'll ask you at home to to
try and find the move see if you can do
it everybody in YouTube sees Bishop e6
check good job good job
but the move for black that wins the
game game ending I say game ending but
white would still have some some threats
obviously your Kings always gonna be a
bit unsafe in this case yes
Queen c3 not quite not quite so you're
not trying to to grab material here if
all you needed to do to win the game was
was grab some material you would take
this bishop and you would win the game
what you're looking for is ways to kind
of counter the white threats right so
you take this bishop his boobs always
gonna be queen eight check you kind of
know this and then you're your problems
that you're running into is if you go
here he's gonna take this pawn with
check you have to spend a tempo on this
now we might go here now he might do
other mean things to you like Bishop
here to here and if you play Bishop b8
once again things like Bishop deform it
should be five of your problems Bishop
a7 is your problem
so you're looking at these moves and
you're trying to find some way to a kind
of lessen less than the threats of it in
fact you can do it with with tempo here
and that's the way to go
for for black some people in YouTube
that actually mentioned the correct move
yeah so Bishop c7 and what happens what
happens now what would white do yeah
Queen a it and I guess you're moving and
after Queen tix this is the the key move
of the variation because if you just
take the bishop now you're kind of
simply transposing why it's gonna hit
you with this move and then hit you with
this move and now you're kind of busted
yeah rook PA is actually a very nice
idea by a by black you delight taking
the bishop for one more turn and now if
white continues with something like
Queen a7 he simply doesn't have the all
the same threats that he used to it's
still very very complicated but by no
means is this is this easy but with this
rook here you're actually keeping an eye
on this b5 pawn and after takes let's
say the game just follows this line that
I mentioned probably gets a little bit
more responsible to to not take this
pawn and just play a move like Queen f5
here we'll say well now what we'll just
take the pawn just for fun so after
Bishop pur you can play York c8 and now
this Queen isn't really making all the
threats that it that it used to be
making which is good news for a for
black because it was making some pretty
scary threats yeah rook d1 is and this
is a key point thankfully for black
these two pieces coordinate very well
together and so you don't really have to
worry about the rope coming to the file
you can always block it off with Bishop
d3 but yeah thank you for the for the
question because this is an important
point in the position that I that I you
know I of course saw also yeah maybe you
can play a move like like rook a here as
well I think Rick a it might even be a
just just a bit better for for black
than than the other line of course if
you go here then there's rook H to b8
and if you come here you can simply
trade Queens and then take the bishop I
might be messing up some lines here let
me let me double check the engine here
but yeah after Queen a7 simply rook a
and this is in fact that the best line
and of course with Queens off the board
black is simply gonna be up a piece here
so this is the winning line that I
missed so after before Bishop c7 is very
nice idea and then you kind of kick the
Queen around get it out of your face
before taking the bishop and white is
kind of left with no threats instead
though I simply captured and my opponent
played the incorrect move Bishop d4 so
d4 and now there's actually a couple
ways for for black to maintain the edge
here yeah yeah no I had plenty of
chances to it to beat mr. mr. o GF here
but you know he played very practically
he played some some sacrifices that
looked a bit dubious and we're a bit
dubious but worked out for him in the
end and after Bishop d4 there's actually
a couple ways to maintain the advantage
if you want to find them at home go
ahead and pause the video I'm not gonna
ask you to here here in classics think
we spend enough time on this the worst
of my losses
Queen f5 was actually one way to do it
the reason I shied away from this is
because there's this very nasty looking
mover ik e 5 and this this was giving me
some trouble you can take this but now
after Bishop takes there's a pretty
significant threat to to this black King
but turns out after rook e5 simply Queen
d7 and black is safe and up a piece the
other way to do it is actually still to
play Bishop c7 and the tactics here are
pretty interesting after Queen a8
now if you take here of course there's
Queen takes but Queen b7 and now simply
still rook b8 and you just leave your
queen under under attack the entire time
and let's say Queen b8 direct to expiate
Bishop takes pawn takes and this endgame
should actually be a pretty pretty nice
one for black with the two bishops two
bishops are very powerful
yeah bright yeah then then simply rook -
yes so it's a similar story here Bishop
takes a five of course if you take I'll
take back and if you take here I'll take
back with the bishop you can play Bishop
takes here but worst case for black okay
you retreat the bishop takes takes and
at the end of the day you still have two
bishops for the rook that's nice
yes so we'll get back to here let's say
Queen Texas we're saying and maybe
there's even some funny business here
with like Queen Queen h4 but let's go
back here yes so this should still be
should be slightly advantageous for
black let me flip on the so yeah it's
like minus one point five minus two
white does have this night nice pun but
after something like this should be five
and Bishop d3 there's a lot of pressure
to the white structure and like also can
make use of this CC pawn with a move
like c5 kind of breaking things open but
yet the two bishops are are actually
really really powerful in an endgame
like this where they're playing against
a rook so you're you're willing to give
up quite a bit if you can get this
imbalance so those were the various ways
I could have won this game and said I
played the horrible horrible move which
is Queen takes h4 everybody hates green
ticks h4 and now after quit a a check I
realized the move I had missed as a move
I've already been showing for a bit it's
this Bishop e5 idea it stops this
checkmating threat and also threatens
the dark squares over here I didn't
really see that this idea was something
that that white had and so after Queen
b7 Bishop c7 my opponent of course plays
Bishop e5 in my head I was only thinking
about Bishop b6 or something like g3
let's say that the Queen goes somewhere
and then Bishop b6 these are the ideas I
was looking at but of course simply
Bishop e5 is as much faster and now
after rook c8
the nice finishing blow from my opponent
does anybody see see a good way to bring
more pieces into the attack or perhaps
pawns perhaps
yes sir Rick on d1 black actually still
has this nice idea of Bishop d3 this is
always gonna hold things together on on
the D file for black
yeah once you see this move you kind of
never go back you just yeah you see this
movement you're like okay I'm happy that
should be enough anybody well everybody
like Turk do you want but yeah Bishop d3
Bishop d3 is holding on for a bit it's
not the key idea Yorick d1 not the key
idea
yeah whites move here to really finish
me off
yeah Peters got it in the YouTube chat
do you guys want a few more seconds not
g3 not g3 this Queens out of play on h4
you like where this Queens at g3 is only
forcing it to better squares yeah simply
b5 and this this pawn is the the light
square attacker that white needed to
really break things open of course it
takes simply Queen d5 check now this
King has nowhere to go everything once I
can even just take the Queen so you
can't take you can't do a lot of things
here if you want to sit at home and be
depressed and find all the ways that
black loses you're welcome to I sat at
the chess board for a while doing that I
decided queen g4 was one of my best rise
my opponent took on c6 and then does
anybody see the the final checkmate in
combination here it's a very fancy move
I'll give you a chance
please dear God somebody find it oh no
look at this game anymore
all right I'll give you a hint but the
Queen here with Czech
stuff
all right more hints let's let's get
through it let's get through it put the
Queen here with check so you can put the
Queen here with check ideally don't lose
your queen in the process ideally
everybody sees it Bishop f6 there you go
only legal move Queen takes f6 King d7
Queen e7 mate and this was the end of
the game so a couple ways to look at
this game nice attacking game by it by a
Wyatt very fighting chess from the
professional fighter
arsalan og of another way to look at it
black kind of played like a [ __ ]
couldn't calculate anything and got
checkmate it and that's that's the way
it goes sometimes but some very
difficult threats of being made by it by
white here this b4 move is is pretty
creative so props to my opponent for
coming up with this one sacrificing his
bishop using this idea of bishop b6
check is is pretty nice fortunately for
him
I knew it shouldn't work I knew it
there's just no way that this should be
working but I was unable to to find it
so uh that's a nice win by arsalan
horrible loss by me and this was
actually a the final round in the
tournament and my team we drew on the
lower three boards and this was the
deciding game so very very sad stuff for
uh for my team our team name actually
was you hate to see it and you really do
just hate to see it don't you
alright after that one let's get a nice
little mouthwash little get that bad
taste out of there yeah so I think he I
don't know if he's ever chests boxed
he's aware of chess boxing I know this
there was some like livestream by it by
a London chess boxing ring and I think
he made an appearance or something and
he was watching but yeah yeah I'm sorry
you missed the intro but my opponent in
that game was actually a professional
UFC fighter as well as a chess player so
MMA fighter not in the UFC but he was
punching people that's all I know
now he was a very nice person I should
say don't want to perpetuate this the
stigma I was never never afraid of my
opponent but okay moving on from that
game we have this game that I played
with the white pieces against Alexander
Megan and this game was the exact
opposite of the last game I'm including
this game because if you didn't watch my
f3 NIMS a lecture on how to win every
time in the f3 NIMS oh here it is again
I used 7 minutes for this game it was
the morning round the night I am round
nobody wanted to be there and so this is
how you win brain-dead games with the f3
NIMS oh okay I'm telling you guys you
got to play this opening you don't have
to think so you play d4 you end up in
the nimzo-indian right you play your
move f3 now your opponents in 1900 never
seen the f3 NIMS own his life he's like
a 14 year old he just no idea so he
plays d5 which is fine a3
it should take c3b take c3 now there is
a very respectable line here for black
that goes with c5 and after C takes D
you actually take this back with the
knight this lines pretty good for black
it equalizes but my opponent castles and
now after C takes d5 you actually can't
play Knight takes d5 due to this nice
trick with E 4 and after Knight c3 just
Queen b3 and things get a little bit
crazy here but after Bishop b2 white is
picking up a piece actually Knight d5
the tactics are a little crazy but this
night does get trapped in the end if you
come back here
there's your ex c1 so white picks up a
piece so I didn't actually have all that
memorized but I knew black couldn't play
Knight takes d5 here so that's why
castles is slightly wrong instead pawn
takes now e3 so black is still not lost
yet black still has a chance to play
some good moves here all you have to do
let's play b6 and Bishop a6 and trade
off this important light squared bishop
but of course your opponent's 1900 he
doesn't know what he's doing in this
opening so instead he plays a move like
rook e8 and now now white is simply much
better
you just develop your pieces c5 was
goodbye my opponent knight c6 is as bad
now white is significantly better
because you no longer had this idea with
Bishop a6 and this Bishop is just too
too powerful for white so okay at this
point I'm still playing all the same
moves that I always play a castle he
plays c4 and who can tell me why this is
a bad move I know some of you are here
for my f3 names Oh lecture why is c4 bad
nobody knows sowhat's White's big idea
in the position what's White's big idea
whole whole point of the f3 names oh
just control this square right white
wants to play E for so the big downside
to playing a 4/4 white usually you can
pretty much always get enough defenders
of the e4 square
thanks to this f3 pawn but it can be
difficult to make sure this D pawn is
defended enough with all this pressure
on it thanks to these pieces so yeah so
C for you simply retreat the bishop and
now for white this pawn is well defended
and you never have to worry about your D
pawn being weak after you play e4 and so
now black is simply I dare say just what
lost here this is just losing for black
if black does want to try there are
actually still some games here he has to
play very quickly on the Queen side with
b5 but it's still simply too slow and
why it's going to be much better instead
my opponent played the nonsensical b6
and now black is is officially I'm going
to say just just lost we flip on the
engine here it's gonna say like plus 2
maybe plus 3 plus 1 plus okay not quite
as much as I thought
so white still can or black still can
maybe survive here only plus 1 but b6 is
very clearly missing the point
black needs to expand on the Queen's
side very very quickly to have counter
chances here so now me is still spending
no time play all the best moves you just
play Knight g3 here you just want to
play e4 this is White's idea you don't
have to think too hard about it and now
for you black players out there you want
to play h5 here with the idea of kicking
this night away but it's still not
really good enough here for black
instead my opponent plays once again h6
missing the point
kind of funny on both sides of the board
he goes one space too short and now this
simply allows of course efore takes
takes and here my opponent and tax my
queen so I moved my queen out of the way
and then my opponent set and looked at
this position for a while and realized
that he was losing realized that this
was just not a good position of course
white is dominate
in the center why it's gonna have ideas
on the queenside with stuff like Bishop
h6 stuff like f6 stuff like e5 and
Queenie for pretty much every idea here
works for white and white simply winning
so my opponent kind of threw in the
towel said all right well I'll just take
your pawns of course though I simply
take back this check is a fork but this
fork doesn't really work especially not
like that simply mission b3 Queen comes
back to d6 now I simply kick the bishop
away and bring the rook to the open file
my opponent plays Queen takes 83 which
is a little bit ambitious bringing the
Queen all the way to the Queen's side to
it to take this pawn and of course
what's the killing blow here for white
how do you finish them off I played this
move with no thought immediately
yeah no no no no I mean why it's
probably winning after Bishop takes h6
cuz white had more pieces to start with
but much better than Bishop h6 is not
rookie one you like this rook where it's
at and you especially like this Queen
where it's at
you don't want this Queen coming back to
the Kings side to it to defend some
important squares not naughty 590 come
on everybody's favorite move rook takes
f6 rook takes f6 is the killer blow
probably all of your moves are still
winning cuz White's up a piece but this
is this is the way to go by far this is
the way to go and so if black takes
how would you continue Bishop h6 isn't
bad but I might like this Knight h5 move
better simply threatening checkmate and
then it's it's all going wrong here for
a for black after King f8 something like
Queen g3 and this King is starting to
get a bit corralled here by by the white
pieces
my opponent actually tried Queen e7
which which now if you're not even
taking the rook then then you're just
losing I actually played the move Knight
h5 here rather than protect my rook
which is a bit mean my opponent plays g6
attacking my Knight Queen g3 skin comes
to h7 now after E 5 white is up to
pieces and they're all in front of the
black King and things are going quite
wrong why it's actually threatening to
take this pawn so my opponent defended
it but now after Queen f4 my opponent
simply resigns there's there's not much
to be done here this threat to the pawn
can only be parried with something like
Queen f8 then there's some nice
sacrifices here
you can take you six play this check the
King has to retreat now just something
like Knight f6 this is becoming very
quickly unstoppable and so my opponent
simply resigned after Queen up four so I
know I went through this game quickly
but it's an ideas it's ideas I've shown
before just in the f3 NIMS oh don't play
like this with black play any no any
number of the good lines here plays c5
play castles and now
if you want to play d5 c5 and then take
back with the knight to do whatever you
whatever you want just just don't play
like this just don't do it anymore I'm
sick of seeing it sick of seeing it dude
I mean I'll take the freewinds but just
stop doing it it's not good it's just
not good do something else I beg you
alright not good for chess not good for
chess I just wanted to stop I just
wanted to stop I mean it makes for nice
games I'm gonna publish a book someday
just 50 ways to not think in the f3 NIM
zone and it's gonna be 50 games exactly
like that every time yeah I'll make a
chess about a repertoire of simple just
games in that line anyways though let's
let's move on to a more classy game here
I actually had the black pieces in this
game against the one and only
Grandmaster Andrew tang anybody in the
room familiar with Andrew tang one
person you've heard of him how old do
you think he is no idea you've just
heard the name alright yeah Andrew tang
is actually a kind of an Internet
personality as well under the name I
think penguin GM is what he goes by of
course he's a pretty young guy I think
he just started in Princeton
we were actually playing the Princeton
18 B team C team one of the teams they
had a lot of teams at this tournament
but Andrew Tang was playing board one so
I had the very daunting task of playing
him he actually played the London
against me with d4 and Bishop f4 and
I've been told by some strong players
the black has some forced draw line here
I didn't know it so I just played chess
played e6 I was told second hand that
Nakamura says that he's had to stop
playing Bishop before against strong
players because they all know this force
draw line I don't know it but probably
if you do some research out there you
can find it but yeah Bishop f4 I simply
play e6 keeping in line with my
repertoire you know the nimzo-indian and
stuff he plays III and I play a little
bit of an offbeat line I just play b6
and Bishop
seven which is totally okay for for
black the idea is you're not really
committing to either of these moves yet
but probably you know you're gonna play
one or both of them in the future
white simply develops with night BD -
now I do in fact play c5 hitting the
center so white plays c3 defending the
center so in simple enough I get castled
and now my opponent simply plays h3 and
now I'm gonna give you a choice between
four moves okay play knight c6 here play
Bishop e7 here play d6 here or you could
play d5 here any of these moves what do
you guys think which one strike you as
as nice yep
d5 why do you want to play d5
yes finally if someone's paying
attention so the whole point of my
opening is I haven't touched these
queenside pieces for what reason have I
not touched these queenside pieces well
I'm waiting for my opponent develop his
Bishop so I can immediately attack it
and trade off White's best piece for one
of my worst pieces so this is the point
of this move order that I've chosen with
with black and if you're paying
attention from the last game you might
have divined this idea for yourself but
this is the point of my pipe and so
developing one of these pieces well this
fine for black normally I much rather
play Bishop a6 and permanently get rid
of my opponent's best piece so that's
why d6 or d5 are both good and I think
you can really have your pick between
them I was a little bit wary of playing
d5 for some reason why why is that why
would I be wary of this move not
actually c4 yeah by giving my opponent
this a 5 square I was actually worried
he might do a very very mean thing to me
and just play 95 and now he's delayed
developing this Bishop for another turn
and this move is becoming less realistic
because as soon as I play here he might
take it and play move like knight c6 and
so things are becoming a bit more
difficult for me that's not to say that
d5 is a bad move in fact it's it's
probably okay for black but I might have
to switch plans here and play something
like Knight f d7 and try to trade off
some pieces like so and play something
like f6 eventually though I mean they're
gonna have to crack and play Bishop a6
or just develop my pieces so I wanted to
stick to my guns here so I played the
move d6 keeping an eye on this g5 square
my opponent finally caves and played
Bishop plays Bishop d3 and I stand up
and cheer and celebrate and play bishop
basics of course offering the trade of
the bishops it's not so easy for white
to decline this trade white doesn't
really want to play the move c4 because
now I can simply take and play a move
like d5
there's someone comfortable pressure
here for white and you don't really want
to play a move like Bishop c2 or b1 for
obvious reasons
it takes away your castling rights and
it's not going to be so easy to get
those back actually so my opponent takes
I take back castles and now let me ask
you what you think the best moves for
black are here you're more or less
developed maybe you want to find a
square for your queen but you don't
really have to do that immediately in
fact you're probably not sure what the
best square for this queen is just yet
so it makes a little bit more sense to
to delay putting it somewhere but how do
you improve your pieces here
yeah nice c7 okay why do you wanna play
in 97 what's the future figure night or
how does this support your your plans
yeah so 95 is one idea but the problem
is with a move like 95 let's say white
plays some natural move White's simply
going to move this Bishop and then
you've kind of walked into White's ideas
right before is gonna come and this
night is gonna have to move again
probably back to c7 which leaves you
with the same question what is your
night doing on on c7 so the argument for
it I think is you do defend this be 5
square which can be pretty relevant here
because a very common plan for black is
to expand on the queenside here with B 5
and B 4 so this is one reason for
putting the knight on c7 but I I still
didn't like it because let's say rookie
1 I play b5 no I really want this knight
on c6 to support this b4 break and so
because of that reason I actually came
up with this move and I Knight back to
be 8 which looks a little bit
counterintuitive but it's actually I
think the best move for black and the
reason is c6 is just a much better
square for this night rather than rather
than a 6 if you support these ideas with
b4 and you control some important
central squares like a 5 and d4 once
again putting pressure on d4 does in
some sense kind of help prevent this
efore break so 98 my opponent plays a4
very astutely recognizing one of the
most common ideas for black i simply
develop my knight back to c6
he plays Knight c4 now this move kind of
makes a threat he might be toying with
the idea of taking here and making use
of the d6 square so I took this
opportunity to make sure that doesn't
happen by capturing on d4 he actually
plays a takes d4 in this case and now I
simply play rook c8 getting the rook to
a half-open file he goes ahead and plays
rook e1 very cleverly noticing that no
tactics really work here for me
I thought for a second in the game maybe
I could get away with Knight takes d4
and after Queen d4 I would have some
some very silly fork like this but he
simply takes all my pawns since it's not
so good for me so thankfully I calculate
that far and notice that that was bad
but with that in mind how do you really
continue here with black it's it's not
so easy to figure out
how do you continue
give you a little bit of time here
because it's not the easiest question in
the world
any ideas so yeah why do you want to
play d5 so so yes and no you said kick
away this night but the problem is with
d5 you're kind of kicking him to a good
square right so not saying d5 is wrong
but what's what's the the idea behind it
yeah that's that's actually the the main
points I think so yes it is good to kick
this night away but you have to realize
that after 95 you're actually quite
happy with this trade this trade is is
nice for black you're opening up the
rook
this Knight was actually kind of in your
way on c6 well it does stop moves like a
a5 and support maybe it'd be for brake
that was becoming kind of less realistic
and this not on c4 was providing some
some pressure one plan that I thought
you guys might mention is to kind of
stick to your guns and play this move a
six was anybody considering it no so the
point with a six would of course be to
play this move b5 still but I was
worried about things like Knight e3 here
and while I might be able to get in this
like b5 move and things like that I
thought that maybe White's play would be
coming a bit faster
with things like d5 and so it's
important to kind of think about these
things and notice how quickly the plans
are kind of coming through because I
think your black would actually be in
quite a bit of trouble so that's why I
kind of discounted this this a6 idea and
instead went for this move d5 and after
the trade simply 94 as as you stated and
so now white goes ahead and plays Queen
e2 and now I started playing chess in
the way that lower rated players love to
play chess I can't I write of players
first I play Bishop H for the strip came
to e1 now I'm highlighting that this
pawn is is actually pretty difficult to
defend
so Andrew simply brought their work back
to f1 and then I said please trade
pieces with me Andrew please tray pieces
with me God if there are no pieces maybe
I'll draw so that's that's what I did
and that's actually not the worst idea
here for black and my reasoning for it
or my justification maybe is that this
bishops are actually on a really useful
diagonal you know it controls a lot of
important squares here while my bishop
does control some squares here it's
really only going to be useful if I'm
I'm getting moves like b5 + b4 in which
I'm simply not here not in the near
future at least and so because this
bishops useful and this Bishop isn't
useful I thought it made sense to try to
to trade them off so that's what I did
Andrew very thankfully helped me out
with that
I went ahead and took my bishop I took
back and he plays this move a five and
here there are some very concrete
threats that that white is trying to
make with a five he's trying to say that
he's gonna take here and after you take
back moves like rook a six moves like a
seven it was like Queen B five they're
all gonna cause some problems for you
because your pawns just a bit weak so I
came up with a way to to kind of deal
with it played this move Queen d2 the
idea being if you capture I've succeeded
and trading more pieces and in fact
things like this shouldn't be too bad
for me if we get to a straight reckoned
game especially because b5 and b4 is
probably going to be achievable here so
Queen d2 and your wanted to win the game
so he played Queen b5 but now I simply
take on a5 and after Knight f3 a move
which I did not expect I thought that if
I played Queen c2 trying to main
pressure on the B to pawn or maintain
pressure on the B to pawn rook c1 would
be problematic for me but who can find
the engine's way to kind of I won't say
win but get a very good position after
rook c1 note that your Queen's trapped
but stockfish and nobody else of course
saw the idea from afar which is to play
the move a six
of course if work the eight your problem
is Queen takes b8 and if you respond
with Queen takes c1 this move and
fortunately comes with check so rook
bait doesn't quite work but a6 does
actually managed to divert this Queen
and after something like Queen b6 thinks
simply what do I think here I I don't
know this was kind of an afterthought
with this long engine continuation maybe
this move maybe this move plenty of
ideas here for for black things like
this could be good
but okay I didn't see all of that so I
simply retreated my queen Andrew takes
on a five
of course my idea is to play York p8
Queenie to defends this pawn for the
moment and now we get this interesting
balance where white doubles districts
but I also double my rooks and in this
case it's going to be favorable for me
if Andrew takes you because I ever takes
this and then there's some very serious
pressure against f2 note that there's no
back rank tricks because my Queen
thankfully defends this square so that's
all covered
so instead Andrew defends his B to pawn
with her up back to a2 now I mix some
lifts for myself but this actually gives
Andrew a little bit of an opportunity
here to improve his chances to move
knight you want actually would have done
it
the idea being you come to d3 with tempo
and defend this pawn and then I have to
put in some extra effort to defend a7
but let's not worry about that too much
Sonny plays g3 it's just a slight edge
for y time and it's kind of a kind of an
afterthought but okay Queen c7 Knight e5
a very similar idea 291 he just wants to
come back to d3 I play an improving move
with the move a5
he plays Knight d3 so now he's made a
threat this pawn is defended so he can
capture here I simply defend the pawn we
see a king G to improving the Kings
position and now after Knight b6 and
that comes in to c5 making a threats so
I defend the threats he plays rook e1
probably actually not the greatest move
here I wasn't totally sure why Andrew
played this one and I don't think it was
quite right I responded with Knight c4
and now best for why it might be to just
defend this pawn with 93 but instead
white played b3 now let's see what do
you guys think the best move for black
is here what can you do you're nice
attacked it's very scary
I'd be terrified I was terrified
my knight was attacked
we're running a bit short on time here
mmm close slightly better than Rick
takes me through Rick takes b3 Admiral
try admirable try giving up the rook for
the night but this one doesn't look
quite as good for for black here not
quite enough comp yes rook takes Knight
is the better way to do it he takes back
of course if takes here you simply take
back and this is great so he takes back
and now you take b3 and you're getting
this pawn for it as well and this is
actually a pretty pretty good for black
black is doing quite nicely here Andrew
played Queen c2 defending this pawn
hitting this truck now the best move is
actually pretty counterintuitive but it
is logical once you see it I played the
move rook b5 but after rook b1 I'm kind
of forced to go in for our exchange of
course I can't take here because this is
checkmate
and the square is covered so I would
lose a queen and so because of that
better is actually to play rook b8 which
you would not expect and after a b-1 now
the idea is you can avoid the trade with
any number of moves
probably rook c8 and now with this extra
rook black is doing pretty well instead
though we see rook could be five and now
rook b1 I played the tactical d4 check
attacking this King King goes to g1 and
then I sat there for a while and I was
calculating 95 9 f3 King f1 you know he
probably takes here I take back there's
c4 there's Queen e2 there's a lot going
on so i sat there calculating it for a
long long time and then I gave up and
took on D took on c3 very quickly the
best line that the computer gives I
think is 95 or 92 with the same idea
actually you can't take this because
I've worked b1 so Rick takes b5 no
Knight f3 Chuck you don't want to step
on the same diagonal as the Queen so you
play King f1 now there's Queen takes b5
c4 is probably White's bus stripe and
now you can simply take here and this is
this is pretty good for black if you do
play Queen e2 I'm just flipping on the
engine because I don't remember
there's Queen b1 check King G 291 check
King age 2d takes c3 and I actually did
get here in my head but I thought this
pawn was way too dangerous for me to
play like this and so I decided not to
go for this line
although stockfish gives Knight f3 takes
c2 and you're just in time you can
respond to c7 by making it Queen so that
was the crazy line that I didn't see
that stockfish likes for me instead of
that though I just took on c3 which is a
pretty big mistake because now after
takes takes okay one a very nice smooth
of course you can't take here due to
this threat and rook a one also
preparing to reroute so good move by
Andrew I simply have to take this pawn
and after Queen C 3 we have this type of
endgame here where it's just a rook for
a knight and while I do still have
technically two pawns for it eventually
White's should be able to take her out
of this apon if he's clever enough we
are running out of time
so I'll go through very quickly Queen d5
trying to unpin Queen b3 trying to pin
very mean of Andrew but I'll forgive
them
Queen d5 rook a for hitting me again I
gave a check here and then I give
another check and after King age 2 it's
actually slightly awkward for black you
can't really get out of this pin but you
can play Queen e2 and now if white were
to capture you get a very interesting
endgame sorry if you want to avoid the
professional you have to go here we get
this end game where I actually have four
pawns and five if you count this a pawn
but it's it's kind of dead to me for a
rook and there are Queens on the board
but probably White has to get the
Queen's off the board if he wants to
avoid this perpetual and it turns out
this endgame should be a draw believe it
or not I was kind of terrified that he
was gonna do this
turns out he wasn't quite happy with it
so he doesn't take my night and said to
play Queen and then said brings this
Queen to f4
I play 92 with the idea of a perpetual
after Queen takes pawn server k3 stops
that idea I now defend my pawn and after
g4 I bring this Knight to e5 and we
finally
off these pieces and now the engine got
very mad at me for playing this move h5
because instead of being four versus
three it turns into three versus three
who would have thought that by putting
my pawn on a square what could be taken
my opponent would take it turns out
though this is this is simply a fortress
which thankfully I found in the game
instead stockfish wanted to play g5
which looks terrifying and I didn't want
to do it turns out this endgame should
simply be drawn I didn't know that I
thought h5 was the best try fracturing
White's pawns and now I actually bring
this Knight back to g5 and go ahead and
play e5 here with the idea being I'm not
allowing f4 if my opponent ever plays f4
I'll take it and then it'll be a pretty
easy draw
so instead King g4 defends this H pawn
and now my drawing idea is simply to
shuffle this Knight back and forth to
the f4 square first my opponent brings
this rook down to a eight and now
there's actually a couple reasons
why black is drawing here a couple
things that need to be true one is after
you move the knight off of f4 it still
attacks f4 so f4 is not a good move for
white and two whenever the King steps to
this square what move should but should
should black play
no no no I'll give you hints you
actually don't want to come back to this
square because after h6 white does have
a very nice checkmating idea and so
you'd be forced to take back like this
and then you're kind of getting killed
you're kind of getting killed here
so you cannot step back to f4 it's not
good enough what you can do is play 94
check and you cover these two squares
and the King has nothing better than to
come back to g4 this is actually what
happened in the game and then very
quickly I'll point out so that's why you
can't play King at 5:00 with the knight
on e6 but why can't you play King at
5:00 here
well it's losing this pawn and so you
still don't have time for this h6 idea
so my opponent instead plays h4 now my
opponent has covered the e6 square but
thankfully I can also shuffle using the
e2 square with the same idea
King f5 still Knight d4 this King comes
to e4 I come back and so andr tried to
make progress and the only other way he
could with h6 I take it and now the
point is white successfully got my King
out of my little hole on h7 but
unfortunately at the cost of a pawn this
is simply drawn somewhere moves were
played King e6 back and now h6 once
again trying to fracture the pawns but
after king f5 attacking f6 I thankfully
I have Knight d5 and after the check I
have 97 and this one's a pretty simple
draw and Andrea let me have it without
too much difficulty here trading off his
last pawn and playing her it takes f6
and so the game was a draw with a nice
little fortress by a by the Black Knight
in the ends holding everything together
just barely so that's how you draw I
don't know the 30-something player in
the u.s. you just play well for a bit
and then forget that you can't really
calculate and then because you can't
calculate end up in a worse end game and
some by some miracle find find a
fortress so that those were some of my
my games from the youth US Amateur teen
East or World Amateur team depending on
who you ask any questions about anything
that happened today
any of these games this one the last one
the first one all right fair enough
thank you all for joining me on this
road to 2000 my name is Caleb Dundee and
I will see you next week
[Music]
you